ce serait un amuse gueule que vous
serviriez un plateau comme ça j'en ferai
mon jeu n'est pas si longtemps si on
voulait offrir un plateau avec
différentes moutarde aromatisées il
aurait fallu à l'hiver des produits
importés mais voilà que des moutardes
artisanale bien de chez nous se sont
fait une place de choix sur les
tablettes des épiceries fines et dans
les marchés publics
pas étonnant puisque lé canada est le
premier producteur de moutarde au monde
on commence à avoir de plus amples simon
aubertin du marché des saveurs du marché
jean-talon à montréal est très au fait
des produits en boutique
beaucoup de moutarde aromatisées
des saveurs boréale des petits fruits
ici sur la table on a deux catégories ce
sont des moutardes qui sont vendus ici
qui sont en partie ou québécoises ou
préparés au québec
tout ce qu'on a ici le cd me tarde qui
sont fait 100 % au québec
donc ici en fait la moutarde est
vraiment monté à partir du grain ont pas
vraiment de la base et tout est fait
exclusivement par la main terrain tandis
que dans ce cas ci la moutarde peut être
préparés ailleurs partout un petit
artisan ou même parfois même dans
certains cas la moutarde importations et
aromatisé ici comme celle ci on voit que
c'est écrit moutarde de dijon donc
automatiquement ses moutons qui importe
et puis parfumé ici elle pas
nécessairement donc un moteur de dijon
c'est pas nécessairement c'est pas une
appellation d'origine contrôlée donc ce
n'est pas nécessairement de moutarde
d'importation de dijon mais c'est quoi
une bonne moutarde artisanale ça prouve
quand même un point piquant faux faux
les cellules essentielles sortir une
belle petite acidité avoir un petit côté
vinaigrée évidemment c'est à sainte
marcelline dans lanaudière que simon
turcotte confiturier et sa co
propriétaire geneviève syndicales ont
tenté l'expérience moutarde fait maison
à 100%
on a fait des expériences sert arrive
damas mais le ça fait dix ans à peu près
alors une jeune danny qu'ont fait les
limites hop c'est quoi une bonne
moutarde qu'est ce que ça doit avoir
comme qualité moi je trouve c'est
beaucoup l'équilibré des saveurs
ça c'est bien important
2 le dosage des ingrédients ça c'est
vraiment la clé vers une moutarde
demande du doigté mais la recette de
base dans le fond c'est le trempage
c'est vraiment avec du vinaigre de l'eau
et du sine mais c'est la quantité de
moutarde blanche où brûlent con mais qui
fait la qualité du produit
le moteur brume et relevé mme abbey
quand tandis que les moteurs blanche
appelée aussi motard john est plus douce
une fois que sa trempe et parlant 18
heures qu'est ce que vous faites là on
est prêt pour le broyage alors le lait
petit greg est gorgé d'eau et de cidre
c'est quand on dit la moutarde me monte
au nez c'est vraiment dû associer qui se
passe quand le petit grain passe dans le
moulin puis que le petit grain de
moutarde éclater leur a fait une
réaction chimique qui fait que la
moutarde et les piquante et orge alors
une fois qu'elle est broyé on peut pas
la cuisine est tout de suite ce serait
beaucoup trop puissant
ça prend un temps de maturation alors là
faut laisser reposer pendant au moins
une semaine avant d'un rom attiser notre
mittal dans une philosophie d'entreprise
les produits simon turcotte parfume
seulement avec des ingrédients de la
région alors là c'est là que je veux
mettre mes ingrédients comme l'érable
emerich beaumier ou le raifort ou à la
fleur d'ail
c'est des ingrédients qui sont très
goûteux vu qu'une williams ou tard c'est
quand même puis ça s'apprend des
ingrédients sont très performants pour
accoter le groupe ika et encres de la
moutarde au marché des saveurs simon
nous fait goûter à des accords moutarde
saucisson et pâté de lapin
mais le plus étonnant c'est le mariage
moutarde et fromages
j ai ren avec la victime la doré justice
une petite pièce de pâte molle on vient
juste ma vie avec un tout petit peu de
l'établissement turc comme ça ceci dit
régulier et il retirable lorsque ça va
de découvertes avant probable une belle
moutarde bas et en dernier lieu un
accord avec alfred de fermer cette
moutarde à l'ancienne au miel
on l'accompagné je fais partie des
québécoises qui met tous deux créés donc
on peut s'amuser à munich allemagne a
pas de les mettre faut sortir des règles
faux faux faux tout essayé
[Musique]